ces leçons de jazz drôle enlevé et
pédagogiques ont conquis le public de
france et de navarre il en présentera
très prochainement à la batterie à
guyancourt et au prisme à elancourt et
il sort en ce moment à tout nouvel album
sous le nom de pierre et marie quartet
voici antoine hervé dans le kiosque on
s'est dit tiens y'a un petit malin qui a
dit et si haut à la place des tierces si
on faisait des cartes cartes
je travaille avec jean françois zygel
sur des leçons musique en classique
parce que j'ai cette double culture
heureusement pour moi et j'ai dit mais
j'ai déjà jean-françois c'est formidable
ce que tu fais pour la musique classique
d'urgence le faire pour le jazz
une sonorité pour les connaisseurs ça
assez mccoy tyner john coltrane guennic
leurs plans
une sorte heures c'est toute l'époque
des années 60 où on a commencé à penser
la musique
le document le lit tous les ouvrages
concernant un compositeur pianiste ou
chef d'orchestre ou saxophoniste
trompettiste jolie touche compile ce qui
m'intéresse je prends des notes je fais
mon petit scénario
j'apprends une quinzaine de ses thèmes
au piano et je vais mélanger sa raconter
son histoire au public avec des
anecdotes drôles je montre au piano
comment ça fonctionne quand est-ce que
c'est improvisé quand est-ce que c'est
écrit qu'est ce qui se passait autour de
lui à l'époque enfin c'est toute une
histoire c'est la lame et la fantastique
histoire du jazz
on est à la fois dans un tempo un peu
rock des pentatonique en afrique n
désaccord mais divo à saas reste du chi
j'arrête
et ça serait de windhof
quand un musicien parle de musique au
public il parle pas de la même chose
qu'un journaliste un journaliste
massacre sa tâche est beaucoup plus à la
biographie ou maisons de disques à la
discographie à des éléments comme ça
alors que nos musiciens on va aller dans
le vif du sujet avec l'instrument sous
les doigts et on va directement montré
aux gens d'autant plus que je mets un
écran un grand écran et j'ai une caméra
sur mes doigts qui montre le clavier et
là on voit bien ce qui se passe sur le
clavier du vieil istres autour d'eux il
ya un grand changement politique on à
kubica heck
le président qui passe avant la paix les
plays zappa ça va tu te rends compte pas
pourquoi on a associé à un mouvement
musical un président chez nous c'est
carla bruni qui tient au fil de ces la
même chose quoi le rire est le meilleur
vecteur de communication et mon but
c'est communiquer ma passion du jazz
donc forcément
et puis ce bon c'est ma nature également
jean nouveau courir et je m'entendais
d'en rire ça me détend et après je suis
je joue mieux du bien et j'aime bien
faire des liens aussi avec la musique
classique la musique occidentale parce
que le jazz et la musique classique ont
énormément de lire dans les deux sens ce
sont influencés
j'ai monté un groupe qui s'appelle
pierre et marie curie quark tête
alors en fait ça a un côté un petit peu
scientifique parce qu'on travaille avec
la musique acousmatique c'est à dire de
la musique qui enregistre des objets de
tous les jours qui les transforme au
moyen d'un ordinateur et qui les rend
musicaux et sur lequel nous on va
improviser après ces séquences sont
créés par véronique wilmart mon épouse
nous venons d'enregistrer l'album que
sont en train de monter et qui doit
sortir le 20 novembre avait distribué
par harmonia mundi et ont fait un
concert d'inauguration le 19 novembre la
veille à l'ermitage dans le 20e à paris
et après antoine hervé elle aussi elle
fait jaser dans les chaumières voici
johanna sonnerie qui nous présente un
nouveau sujet de la rédaction
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences emmanuel
dardenne qui s'entraînent à l'escrimé
est en fête
écuyer l'escrim fait partie de sa
formation à l'académie du spectacle
équestre de bartabas un lieu prestigieux
qu'il a intégré dès son ouverture en
2003 un jour j'ai entendu parler que
bartabas créer une académie à versailles
qui recrutent et eu que des filles donc
j'ai quand même tenter ma chance
j'étais sélectionnée pour aller à
aubervilliers pour pour passer les
auditions et puis ça s'est bien passé on
peut dire des manuels qu'il est né dans
l'équitation une passion héritée de son
père vous sortez de la maison je faisais
5 mètres j'avais les écuries donc à
trois mamies à cheval et j'ai grandi à
cheval quoi j'ai jamais connu de poney
toujours des grands chevaux à auzat j'ai
fait mon premier spectacle
la première représentation en public
avec mon papa emmanuel a effectué son
service militaire à la guerre de
républicaine de paris et à continuer
d'enchaîner les spectacles avant de
rejoindre les grandes écuries de
versailles aux côtés de bartabas
emmanuel est aujourd'hui écuyer
titulaire il côtoie des écuyers confirmé
qu'ils participent au spectacle de
bartabas depuis quelques années il forme
aussi des cavaliers en stage qui
intégreront le spectacle équestre
après un ou deux ans d'apprentissage on
est trois être là depuis le début
et il ya en plus nous avec l'or avec
leur guillaume en a
les coordinateurs artistiques et
pédagogiques c'est-à-dire qu'on vague
leurs séquelles du spectacle en règle on
voit quand ça va pas aller le transfert
de chevaux contre le malade en prendre
un autre
une journée type commence vers 7 heures
chaque écuyer dispose d'environ 4
chevaux ils sont une dizaine en tout à
se répartir 44 bête balade dans le parc
du château détente à la longe répétition
de chorégraphies ou exercice de dressage
chaque homme organise son travail avec
ses chevaux sur la semaine à savoir qui
à six jours du collège de repos il ya
six jours donc deux jours de spectacle
samedi d'image de il reste quatre jours
pour travailler le cheval un dehors des
spectacles
il ya plus de ça il faut suivre les
cours à l'académie on a des cours de
kyudo c'est du tir à l'arc du tir à
l'arc japonais avec un arc dissymétrique
ajoutez à cela les cours de chant
d'escrimé artistique de pilates et de
danse
ne l'oublions pas il s'agit d'une
académie de spectacles équestres
l'enseignement dispensé est gratuit et
chaque écuyer touche un salaire
les écrits par exemple à vienne en
autriche qui gagne je crois à 8000 euros
par mois un nouvel an est bien loin je
dirais qu'un écrit en france gagne entre
eux dire et 2000 euros et au mieux 4
mire le gain ne constitue aucune
motivation est régulier c'est avant tout
comprendre et communiquer avec son
cheval mais c'est aussi mettre sa
passion au service de l'art et du
spectacle
entre les chorégraphies à deux chevaux à
trois quarts ou ca
richebourg chorégraphies des scream avec
six chevaux argentin sans oublier les
solos au trot au galop et les combats
des scream la création de bartabas
intitulé la voie de l'écuyer est à
découvrir tous les samedis et dimanches
aux grandes écuries de versailles
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de regarder la rediffusion du kiosque le
compositeur pascal dusapin présentera
son fameux opéra pour enfants intitulé
momo les 9 et 10 novembre théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la chanteuse sandra nkaké quant à elle
sera le 10 novembre au prisme à
elancourt le 10 novembre également la
merise attrape fêtera l'humour africain
avec deux one man show bienvenue o kwatt
de valérie nono est chiche l'afrique de
gustave akakpo et retour au prisme les
16 17 et 18 novembre de pièce de pierre
note à voir en une seule soirée sortir
de sa mère et la chair des tristes qu
est comme d'habitude vous pouvez
retrouver ces dates ainsi que l'ensemble
de la programmation des salles
saint-quentinoise sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affiche
et n'oubliez pas tous les mardis vous
pouvez gagner des places de spectacle
sur le site du kiosque www.kia.ca qui
point fr chanceux
le cachet de la balle